our next guest may be small but he packs
a big sound artists like pharrell
questlove lenny kravitz you know some of
those guys are amazed by his musical
abilities and he's racked up millions of
views on instagram and guess what he's
only six years old take a look
i'm gonna add some guitar
[Music]
it's just what i need i'm gonna add some
blueberry
i'm gonna know what's that
[Music]
please welcome miles bonham also known
as miles music kid
hi miles
how are you doing i'm doing good what
grade are you in miles
i
am in kindergarten
oh my gosh
that's amazing can i ask what is your
favorite subject my favorite subject
is
music
because i just love music really are you
gonna play something for us well first
um
two instruments are actually missing
um
the first one is actually a crowd here
and then we have the second one is the
guitar right there so
when i get a big hand raise
our crowd is gonna have the best cheer
okay so yeah
right
[Applause]
okay
now this is you guys
you got a little sneak paper whatever
that's us
yeah
that's so cool then what do you do with
that
we're gonna chop it up
then i'm just gonna
make it sustained a little and i'm gonna
add some tremolo that pans it left and
right
and then
i have my guitar
now it's time for the guitar
okay and i'm gonna play the guitar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
miles it's so good
oh my gosh
i mean miles i really admire you and i
have kids my daughters are seven and
nine and i watch what you do
and i'm just amazed by it and there's
one instrument that you want to learn to
play next right what is it um i'm
warning
trombone but i really want to play
violin really
okay well i have a surprise for you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
i've been waiting to have a violin and
then here we we put it look your name is
on the back
god miles music kid
so thank you for coming on the show and
showing all of your skills suggesting
some new music and inspiring us all
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you kyle so much
[Music]
you